Lucy Powell a good morning to you Lucy
Powell do you have confidence that your
counterpart would have fired him if he
hadn't resigned
well no because he should have been
fired weeks ago I think this has been
evident now for some time and it's been
clear that it's it's caused Untold
damage to the reputation of the BBC that
the that Richard Sharp has remained as
chair in this during this time and it
was clear some weeks ago that he failed
to disclose this cozy sort of murky
relationship with the Prime Minister who
went on to appoint him at the same time
he was helping facilitate this loan and
rushy sunak and the conservative
government should have sacked him weeks
ago but I'm afraid this is a pattern
we're now seeing time and time again
that they are more interested in saving
their mates in these jobs whether it's
Dominic Raab or Owen Patterson or now
Richard Sharp and they are in doing the
right thing for the country and that's
why I don't have faith but what I want
to see now is some very clear leadership
from the government that they are going
to put in place a truly independent and
robust process to appoint his successor
so that we can never end up in this
situation again and causing so much
damage to the BBT BBC through what has
been a very important and difficult time
for them
what did you make of his resignation
statement and the fact that the BBC
boards still seemed to support him
I don't think he's understood the
severity and the seriousness of this
situation and seeing this as some kind
of technical breach these rules around
disclosure exist entirely for these
eventualities because you have to
declare at the time you're applying for
these jobs to for any perceived or
actual
um interest that may then if they've
come to light put the reputation of the
BBC at risk and his failure to disclose
them and then the fact that they did
come to light absolutely has done Untold
and you know possibly unrecoverable
damage to the reputation of the BBC and
the position of chair and that's why he
needed to go weeks ago and he's
misunderstood all of that and he's
clearly misunderstood that even today
but that's why rushi sunak should have
sacked him before waiting for this
report a report which I instigated not
the government I asked for this inquiry
that's why the report came to me first
this morning
and uh you know it shouldn't have taken
labor and me to instigate it the
government should have acted Russia soon
actually to show some leadership sacked
him weeks ago and then put in place a
robust process to appoint his successor
and restore some faith and trust in the
BBC there's a familiar pattern isn't
there in the way that
um The Narrative is being handled we saw
it last week with Dominic Raab who
clearly had Advanced sight of the KC
report that was coming out and was able
to control uh really what was being said
about it and that's exactly what we've
seen with Richard Sharp and with both of
those resignations it's avoided putting
the prime minister in a difficult
position
absolutely we are now seeing a pattern
of behavior the Prime Minister it seems
unable to uh take on the vested
interests of of his friends and his
close uh confidants who he and his
predecessors are you're appointing to
these public appointment uh positions
it's kind of cronyism and sleaze at its
worst uh the Prime Minister has been
unable to act in a way in which she
should uh which was that he was really
the only one he and the culture
secretary were the only ones who had any
power to hire or fire the BBC chair
nobody else did I called for this report
to bring to light these issues and to
make it clear that he had failed to
disclose uh this relationship and
disclose these arrangements and he had
had and he should have been sacked ages
ago and we've still not heard from the
government or is she sunak about that uh
today I'm sure we'll hear some warm
melee uh words uh later today and puts
it all on on Richard Sharp but this is
where leadership comes in and this is
where we need to see some proper
leadership and and I want to see the
government now leading and making sure
that there is a truly independent and
robust process to appoint the successor
so that we can't have these allegations
of cronyism and sleaze damaging and
tarnishing the BBC Lucy however you look
at it the BBC chair is always a
political appointment isn't it it's it's
license fee funded and therefore the BBC
chair has always had been really there
at the at the appointment of the
government of the day whether it be
labor or conservative
well look I think this is about
some kind of of democratic oversight or
accountability that's why we do have the
process of the select committee is
supposed to you know look into these
appointments as well but they too were
kept in the dark about some of these
details when they were scrutinizing this
appointment we do have to have some
democratic uh oversight to these
positions but we also have to ensure
that the process that is arrived at is
uh not only independent but seen as
being independent there were some other
criticisms about the process in this
report uh for example that government
ministers and advisors throughout the
appointment of Richard Sharp made it
very clear to the media and others who
their preferred candidate was for this
job thereby clearing the field of
anybody else who might have applied for
this position and and the report today
recommends that sort of behavior stops
it makes some other recommendations as
well about uh enhancing and strength
sensiting this process but I think the
government should be going further on
that really so that it can provide that
reassurance to license fee payers to the
vast majority of the British public that
this process is independent we get the
best person uh for the job yes of course
the the government of the day probably
has to to sign off that at the end of
the process but they shouldn't be
um going out to their their very cozy
network of mates uh to to get one of
them to apply clearing the field of
everybody else and then rubber stamping
them uh getting the job at the end you
know we've got to see an end to that
process and that's why I set up a an
independent review panel to advise labor
so that how we cannot do that ourselves
but could you not say that actually the
Prime Minister has potentially pulled a
Blinder here because the the situation
the controversy with Dominic Robb the
controversy with Richard Sharp could
have been very uncomfortable for him
indeed they've both gone he hasn't had
to fire them and now we're in a run-up
into the local elections we've got the
coronation the electorate's going to
forget quite quickly aren't they
well I don't see it like that I think
that the job of prime minister is to
show leadership to sort these problems
out before they get worse and worse
um what we've seen over the last few
weeks uh when the BBC has been faced
with some very difficult questions and
some difficult issues particularly over
the Gary kalinica Gary lineker Affair is
that we've had a BBC chair Missing in
Action a BBC chair who has himself
through his uh failure to disclose uh
his interests has brought reputational
damage to the BBC during this time the
longer and longer that that has gone on
the deeper and deeper that damage uh has
been and is
um and that's why he should have been uh
sacked a long time ago and I think that
the public are now really starting to
see a pattern of behavior here which is
a prime minister hiding away sitting on
these reports hiding behind
investigations which in this case I
instigated hiding behind them and
waiting for people to fall on their
sword rather than doing the right thing
for the country
um and sacking these people and and
helping to move on
just a final question for you which is
uh related to all this um
in the name of transparency and
Declaration of conflicts of interest
um should sue gray say when she first
started talking to the labor party in
secure starma and whether or not that
was before or during her investigation
into the goings-on at number 10.
well that appointment is all subject to
an independent process as well where all
of this information is is is laid bare
and is is made clear but my
understanding uh is absolutely that
those conversations did not take place
uh during that investigation absolutely
not because at the time kissed armor had
a chief of staff and there was no
vacancy and that vacancy only became uh
open uh last uh Autumn and and uh that's
when care began the process of looking
for a chief of staff but we'll see the
outcome of the akoba uh process there
which is absolutely right and we've said
we'll stand by that all right Lucy Bell
good to talk to you this morning thank
you
thank you